[Music]
hello everyone let's have a look at the
introduction of Jenkins and what it is
basically
now Jenkins is primarily a build and
release tool it was written by the
original community as a build and
release tool they did not target it as a
continuous integration continuous
deployment or an orchestration tool it
was simply used for releasing builds to
production but now Jenkins has a lot of
other uses like it's a continuous
integration tool it allows developers to
make sure that their environments have
the exact same code as their code
repositories so this is true for every
environment so let's say there is the
dev environment
now if Jenkins has uses CI tool in an
environment and make sure that every
comment that goes to a repository is
mirrored in the environment as well
Jenkins is also used as a continuous
deployment tool it allows you to push
your code in other words every time you
do a commit it allows you to push it to
production through a series of quality
gates and a lot of tests it is also used
by some people especially the DevOps
community as an orchestration tool so
people use it as a scheduler or an
Orchestrator to kick off their chef
recipes puppet modules or chef cook
books or ansible play books or any other
ad-hoc scripts it's an open source tool
so there is no license for it and
although there are a lot of companies
who provide enterprise Jenkins and
hosted Jenkins but the community mostly
uses it as an open source tool because
it is quite robust it's written in Java
and for Java applications initially when
Jenkins was initially started it was
only used for building and deploying and
testing Java applications but now things
have changed and it's used for many
different applications it can be PHP
Ruby on Rails Java angularjs every
application is now being employed by
using Jenkins ok now let's take a look
at who uses Jenkins primarily build and
release teams of organizations who are
responsible for building software and
releasing it into production servers
DevOps teams which manage the
environment as well as the automation
framework like chef or ansible they use
Jenkins for running their
configuration management tool agents and
dev teams obviously because they want to
have some tool that lets them deploy
their code so dev teams use it primarily
as a click button thing they can just go
and click the button and they can have
the code in the respective environment
now there are a lot of other uses but
these are the most popular
so why Jenkins why do so many people use
it why is it used in every dev ops JD
and why is it so widely used now there
are a couple of reasons for that for dev
teams it gives you one-click deploys
it's got a very nice UI which it
supports and there are a lot of custom
themes that can be installed it's free
so there's no cost attached to it and
that makes it very popular apart from
that it is robust and very reliable it
has a good release cycle now the plug-in
support is also very good
you've got plugins for almost everything
you've got plug-ins for database
integration plug-ins for Google Cloud
integration there are plugins for maven
and grayble gulp and all the PIM tools
you have plug-ins for integration for
any third party slap integration is
there you have github integration
bitbucket among others so there's a good
ecosystem of open-source plugins which
again are free and you don't need to pay
anyone for those there are scripted
builds so in addition to the plugins
supported builds you can have bills
which are scripted this gives you the
flexibility of having your own scripts
to be done by Jenkins you can have
multiple pipelines in Jenkins so you can
have your workflows automated using
Jenkins and you don't have to worry
about manually clicking or scheduling
tasks you can adjust the schedule of the
initial task and the pipeline will take
care of it it has got good OS support so
basically it is run on almost any OS
windows linux ubuntu debian Red Hat sent
us even through Linux you can compile a
Jenkins binary and there is good
community support you can go to Stack
Overflow or their own community forums
and you'll find support and almost every
issue you will find in the first or
second Google answer
Jenkins is inherently fast since it's
written in Java and it's reliable I've
never seen a Jenkins server crash unless
you do something nasty with it
in general it works just fine even with
rolling updates with updates that do not
work well with your builds will still
work in the same way now we will have a
look at the Jenkins demo so we will be
initially setting up this machine and
the base machine can be on AWS on Google
Cloud VMware Workstation or an active
VirtualBox it depends on what you want
to use and where you have an account AWS
provides you a free trial for one year
and Google Cloud gives you $200 a VMware
Workstation is your own local machine so
you don't need to pay anyone so we'll be
starting with the installation of the
package on the Bluetooth 16 point o4
will install the suggested plugins and
we'll set up an initial user we'll set
up a matrix authentication and we'll be
creating users for that we'll have a
look at the plugins we will have a look
at inbuilt installations like Java maven
and aunt and docker plugins we'll also
look at how we build a hello world
application now I'll be using a virtual
box here and I have here a pre-installed
version of ubuntu 16.04 LTS I'll be
using that as the demo based platform so
let's just get the VirtualBox started
and we can go from there
[Music]
so this is my virtual box I've already
installed one to 16.04 I have allocated
four gig of ram and 4 V CPUs because it
requires adequate juice to run
effectively now you can run it on 2 gig
of ram but it won't be running the most
optimal
again you can see I have given it
forgave a group of RAM and 4 CPUs make
sure you adequately adjust the RAM of
CPUs according to your system
configuration operating system
you
Oh in a moment you'll see the login
prompt from ubuntu 16.04 so i'll be
logging in as the root user and the
password for this machine is Red Hat
written Red Hat
now this is the open to prompt I'm going
to find out the IP address because I
want to use the terminal here so this is
if config
192 168 point one point one one five
that is the IP address of my machine one
more thing to note is that you should
ideally have the bridged network so that
you get the same IP address range as
your local laptop now if for some reason
it does not work you can use the host
only in the NAT adapters in combination
but since it works most of the time it's
fine so I'll be logging into this
machine using SSH so window users should
use puddi so let me demonstrate how to
do that using Pudding so I'll be using
so window users should be using putty
for SSH into Linux machines so I have a
Windows machine here in a remote desktop
session so let me show you how to SSH to
this machine using puddi puddi is
available on the internet at their
website so you can google that and find
it this is at petite org make sure you
download it for your specific operating
system so for Windows you can download
either 64 or 32 bit
now I have a Windows machine here so
this is how booty looks it is a remote
SSH client
now the only argument it takes as a
minimum is the IP address or where you
want to SSH so I'll put in the IP
address
one sixty eight point one dot one one
five it asked me for a username now let
me increase the font size you can edit
the appearance of your putti terminal
depending on your needs so I'll make it
16
it asked me for the username and
password I'll specify root and Red Hat
as his username so this is the putti
console or the remote SSH console
so I'm gonna use this on my Mac so Mac
users should use the terminal that comes
by default so on Mac you see SSH root at
one ninety two dot one sixty eight dot
one 105 so this basically gives you an
inbuilt terminal you don't need to
install the putty now when I press ENTER
it asked me for a password
just enter Red Hat is the password so
the first thing you have to do on a
Linux machine when you are installing
fresh software is to change the hostname
to change the hostname I'll edit the
file using the vim editor on the
hostname so at CTC hostname when I open
that in the text editor you can see
there is texture Ubuntu
I'm gonna delete that by going into
insert mode by pressing I so I puts me
in insert mode and I can clean this up
I'll name this Jenkins - server and say
I'll save this file and reboot the
machine now this is very important when
you are accessing machines remotely
because you have multiple terminals open
and you should be able to easily
identify them at least in the local
machines that is which machine belongs
to which terminal the reboot is required
for this machine to take the new
hostname this might take a couple of
minutes for the machine to reboot
it's rebooted now if I log in again to
this you can see the prompt has changed
it says root Jenkins - server so now go
ahead and install Jenkins on this
machine using W get W get is a command
which allows me to download stuff from
the internet now since I don't have a
GUI here I have to download stuff from
the internet so I'll use W get for that
and I'll be downloading the Jenkins key
initially so I'll download the key from
package dot Jenkins at i/o Debbie and
Jenkins ioki it's available on the
internet so I'll invoke W get in the
quiet mode and I'll type HTTP package
Jenkins dot IO for slash Debian
[ __ ] slash Jenkins that IO that key and
I want to add this key directly to my
local apt cash so I'll pipe it and I'll
type sudo apt key and - so this command
I have written it will download the
Jenkins key and it will add it to local
app cache
and when I press ENTER it says unable to
resolve host Jenkins server this is a
common warning because when you are
doing a sudo the sudo tries to resolve
your local machine so it's warning which
can be ignored it's because I don't have
a local DNS server here which gives me a
fully qualified domain name but after
that you see there is an okay which
means that this key has been
successfully imported now the purpose of
this key actually on the internet when
you're installing popular software a lot
of times hackers try to spoof packets
and they will try to send you bogus
artifacts or bogus IP ms which might
have a virus in order to safeguard
against that and to make sure that the
package you are getting is the one you
intended there's a public and a private
key and we just imported that key and we
have saved that so whenever we install
Jenkins from the repository we will be
assured that we have the same package as
the Jenkins community had intended for
us okay the next step is created Jenkins
dot list file so that my apt knows where
to install Jenkins from so I'll go to eg
c4 slash apt
sources dot lists at D and here I'll
create a file named Jenkins that lists
in this file I'll define a specific
format for downloading a debian package
from a stable Jenkins repository so I'll
go into insert mode and type dev HTTP
package Jenkins
that I Oh
Debian - stable binary okay and then
forward slash so this is the format
which you specify in a list file this is
the input of apt and it basically
contacts the remote Jenkins package
repository to download the Jenkins
binary I'll save this file by hitting
escape semicolon WQ exclamation mark and
I'll be updating my local apt cache to
update the package repository indexes
because I've added a new list of
packages and are at that remote location
and I want my local machine to know that
there is a new list now I want to add
that list to be updated in the local
cache the command for that is apt hyphen
get space update so this is a package
manager for Ubuntu 16 and a boot to
other versions so I'll be using that for
updating apt cache now my apt cache has
been updated I'll be proceeding with the
installation of Jenkins using the apt
package manager so I'll say apt I can
get install Jenkins okay when I press
ENTER it automatically finds a
repository where I need to install
Jenkins from it shows me that the
following packages have been installed
so these are the suggested packages
and these are the new packages which
will be installed so it asked me for
confirmation I'll say Capital y and
press Enter
you
it takes some time to download the
package repositories
it's downloading the debian package from
the Ubuntu repository
so the download is completed and it has
started to unpack the software it's
unpacking Jenkins and all the
dependencies and installing them
automatically
now Jenkins has been successfully
installed on this machine and one of the
features of Debian is that it
automatically starts the service so if
you want to check the port the service
is running on the Jenkins service you
can do a net stat - NAU TPL grep listen
and you can see it's a Java process
which is running at port 808 oh so you
can also do a PS fax and if you see
there is a Jenkins running on port 8080
now let's find out the IP address of
this machine again and let me go to that
IP and port 8080 so I'll go to 192 168
dot one dot 1 1 5 4 8080 which is
specified by semicolon 8 0 8 0 when I go
to that we see unlocked Jenkins to
ensure Jenkins is securely set up by the
administrator a password has been
written to the log this has all the
features added to Jenkins it allows us
to make sure that no one else starts up
the initial admin user so this feature
was not there before and sometimes it
cause security issues so people keep
scanning internet ports for vulnerable
software this makes sure that the only
person having access to the initial user
is the one who actually has access to
the instance in other words the admin of
that instance now since I have installed
this on my local machine my on my a boon
to 16.4 local server I know that this
file is there so I'll copy this and I'll
open that file because it has the
initial password so this is the initial
password so which has been written to
this file as a safeguard
now I'll be copying this password and
putting it in the administrator password
and I'll click continue
now this will give me two options either
the suggested plugins or you can select
the plugins you want to install now I'm
gonna go ahead with the suggested
plugins because because it is the best
initial pack you should have at least
the basic things you need this includes
the folders plug-in the OS w s AP markup
formatter plug-in build timeout plug-in
credentials binding plugin and a lot
more these are the minimum recommended
requirements
it takes a couple of minutes for these
plugins to get installed
you
so the installation is now complete we
will be creating our first admin user
I'll name the user admin and password is
password password repeat and I'll name
the user as admin user and I'll give a
dummy email address admin at localhost
com
I'll click on save and finish and then
click on start using Jenkins so this is
the Jenkins dashboard you are seeing
right now now the first thing we want to
do is create some users so I'm going to
go to manage Jenkins
configure global security
before you create users you need to
enable the matrix authentication plugin
now there are two ways of user
authentication and authorization in the
authentication space you have Jenkins
own user database so if you are a small
startup or a small company with say five
to ten users you can use the Jenkins own
user database you can also have an LDAP
server where you can connect and
authenticate users so if you already
have an LDAP server in your
infrastructure and you're setting up a
Jenkins server just integrate with that
LDAP server and you should be fine you
need to populate the LDAP server IP and
port for this demo we will be using the
Jenkins own user database
now in terms of authorization now logged
in users can do anything so I'll be
switching that to matrix based
authentication where I need to
specifically assign permissions based on
whether I want it overall contentious
agent job run view SCM permission so
I'll be adding the admin user to this
matrix and I'll be giving overall
administrator privileges because this is
the admin user and I'll now be enabling
signup where I'll be creating new users
I'll click on allow users to sign up and
then click Save now I'll log out of this
user and create a new test user so we
can create an account I'll create a
read-only user so I'll say read-only set
my password as password password and
then the name as read-only
read only at localhost comm i'll click
on sign up now I've signed up but when I
go to the top page it says access denied
read-only is missing the overall read
permission so I'll say logout I'll go
back to my admin user and give this user
read permissions
so I'm logging back into my admin user
I'll click on manage Jenkins go to
configure global security in the matrix
authentication you see it's not added
yet so I'll add the read-only user here
read-only then click on add now I have
provided overall read permission and
I'll click on apply and save now when I
go to that user it will be able to read
every build so this is a good practice
you can get read-only access to your
developers to your testing teams so that
they don't change any build and you can
have admin access yourself the other
thing I want to show you is the global
tool configuration so you can add in
build binaries so let's say you have a
Java project you can add the Java JDK
here you can name it Java it will
install automatically at the first build
and you can click on agree and the java
SE development kit License Agreement you
can also add get so you click on install
automatically and get will be installed
and you can add Gradle you can name it
dradle you will install this version
automatically so add maven an ant in a
similar way these are all build tools
you use in your builds so maven and you
can also install a docker binary you can
name a docker and keep the installation
route as /home forward slash or you can
keep it as or /opt and click on install
automatically and then click on apply
and save so each of these binaries will
be installed automatically based on
whenever they are invoked from a build
now coming back to the build part we
will be creating a couple of sample
builds so I'll click on create new jobs
and I'll say sample hello world build
and I'll click on create as a freestyle
project you can have pipeline external
jobs multi configuration projects but
for this we'll be focusing on the
freestyle build freestyle build gives
you good flexibility in terms of what
you want to do you can modify the build
according to your needs so click on OK
and it will show me a build
configuration page so this is the build
configuration page where you can specify
build triggers building
post build actions and source code
management so I'll be going here and
adding a build step and I'll say execute
shell so I'll be executing a shell
command called hostname and I'll just
click on save when I click on save this
build is configured now I want to run
that hostname command so when I click on
build now
we'll see it's running that build
it's downloading the JDK
because we have specified this although
we are not using this in the build but
it has to install JDK because we've
specified that in the configuration
so as Jenkins initiates the first build
it downloads every configuration we
specified in the global tool
configuration page it takes a couple of
minutes for this download to happen
it will then install ant great little
maven docker and get still installing
Java JDK
after the installation it has
successfully run the hostname and it is
showing the Jenkins server here
now I have the hello world repository
here on github and I want to show you
how to clone this repository using
Jenkins so this was a sample hello world
build we'll be creating another build
called sample clone project so you
script your builder interface sample
click on ok I'll be using the get plugin
to clone that git repository so I'll go
here and specify get I'll specify the
HTTP credentials or the HTTP URL here in
the build and then I won't add any
credentials because this is an open
repository
save I'll go and build this project
so you see the build is scheduled you
can see it has cloned this repository
hello will get so this is how you can
clone projects you can run your own
shell scripts on top of that you can
also run maven dependencies now if you
go to Jenkins you click on new item
let's say we create a sample maven build
we will use a freestyle project click on
OK
so you can go ahead and invoke a
top-level maven target so let's say
there's a goal - P P MD semicolon PMD
let's say you want to use the
programmatic mistake detector you can
specify this or you can use the
programmatic mistake detector test if
you want to use the unit it all depends
on how you write that into your P om XML
and then you click on apply and save so
you have to make sure all of the logic
in your build is continuous and it works
seamlessly this is all for the Jenkins
introduction thanks a lot for your time
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here